all right we are now live for February's
first oh now it looks like we're now
live for February's First Philosophy
pop-up and I put the topic to the pole
in my patreon site I let my patreon
supporters vote to some degree I wanted
to do something since it's a you know
February and we had Valentine's Day on
or do something that had to do with
romantic love so I gave them the option
between Plato and and you know the
symposium and Phaedrus Aristotle and
what he has to say
the Stoics and Eloise and Abelard the
two star-crossed lovers as we sometimes
say ill-fated in the Middle Ages and
then anything else that they might want
to do and the Stoics one out I think
with a Villard and Eloise as a distant
second and Plato a distant third so that
is what we're going to talk about today
and you know this is something that I've
written about and you can also find a
nice video from stoic on 2018 in my
channel as well if you do a little bit
of looking around for it stoicism
actually does have a good bit to say
about romantic relationships some of it
directly and some of it I think things
that we can we can sort of read into it
and extend into our own lives in the
present so it's not like you know
epictetus or Marcus Aurelius or Seneca
had dating apps to think about or
anything along those lines but you could
apply it to that or you could think
about you know people being concerned
about being friend-zoned and how they
should how they should approach that and
and what do you do if you've got a crush
all those sorts of things I think the
Stoics actually have some some useful
things to contribute so what we'll do is
I'll talk for a little bit about the the
general idea and a little bit about some
of the reefs
that are out there if you want to do a
little bit of reading in the stoical
corpus and then I'll take questions and
comments and just go from from there
with all of those I'm only going to go
for about an hour this time in parks I
have so much grading to get caught up on
and I'm teaching you know five classes
this semester so there's there's a lot
going on I see a few thing comments here
people are asking how far we're into
this that they like the views or like
like the videos if you're getting ask a
question make sure that you've actually
written the whole question out so I
don't have to do a lot of work to figure
out what you're actually asking about
and then yeah like jay says I'll do an
opening speech then I take questions
from everyone that's that's the mo for
these philosophy pop-ups so you know
stoicism and and romantic relationships
or other types of relationships as well
what do they have to say one of the
things I want to get out of the way
right at the beginning I actually had
somebody in my Twitter feed asked about
this you know I mentioned that there's a
difference between what we call
uppercase s stoicism and lowercase s
stoicism uppercase s stoicism is actual
stoic philosophy or ways of living in
the present that are in some way
inspired by that or are taking off from
that so if you're not actually like
reading Epictetus or Seneca or Marcus
Aurelius or at least some decent you
know secondary sources on them you're
not a stoic in the capital s sense just
being tough doesn't make you a stoic
being unemotional doesn't make you a
stoic as a matter of fact it would make
you not a stoic you know if you were
totally lacking emotions because the
Stoics thought they were good emotions
that you you should have loved being one
of them and then we can talk about the
lowercase s stoic as being sort of the
cultural stereotype of the tough you
know resilient doesn't feel or show pain
doesn't really have emotions or
their emotions deep down inside and
that's not stoicism in in the classic
sense that may be what we call stoicism
today and you know there's there's I'm
not going to say it's illegitimate to
talk about that but you should always
use a lowercase s in talking about that
right so yeah we want to make a
distinction between that what I'm going
to talk about today really doesn't have
to do with lowercase s stoicism but if
people want to bring that in we
certainly can what I'm talking about
today draws from actual stoic philosophy
so I mentioned that I would I would talk
about a few resources and and where we
really ought to start is by talking
about which Stoics actually had anything
to say about romantic relationships so
who would that include well one
important person is somebody who
unfortunately we don't have that much
from Busoni estroux ffice right Missoni
estroux ffice has this entire lecture
about what a good marriage ought to look
like and he sets out a plan for it which
you know stresses not just producing
children but also producing a kind of
bond between the two people involved in
the relationship that was really central
to him a lot of people read him
especially a lot of conservatives they
pick up on him and they're like oh you
know this is very good it's a
traditional conception of marriage
yes it's a traditional conception of
marriage that many conservative married
people never live up to because they
don't actually love each other they
don't actually develop a real
relationship of respect between each
other I should mention that Musso Gnaeus
Rufus was also somebody who believed in
gender equality you could see that in
his lectures men and women should be
educated for the same virtues and should
be educated in the same way rather
revolutionary thing to say at the time
for a philosopher or anybody in
greco-roman culture Zeno apparently had
a long discussion about marriage and
seem to have advocated something like
free love in his Republic we don't
actually have the Republic so
don't we don't know what he what he
indeed said and and a lot of other stoic
thinkers are supposed to have written
interesting dialogues or treatises
having to do with eros romantic love and
desire as well as with marriage and
other things what we do have is here
achlys the stoic and you can easily get
his stuff you can't actually find it
online as such we can easily buy the
translation it's quite cheap you can get
that from from him and he's got a
discussion about marriage in there then
you've got people like epictetus you
know Seneca discussing it here and there
I think that can be quite useful you
also probably want to take a look at
[Music]
areas didymus his epitome of stoic
ethics again a text that you can get
fairly cheaply arias didymus wasn't
himself a stoic but he did sort of
summaries of stoic doctrine and in there
it talks about the wise person here's a
really interesting passage the wise
person is you know has all these virtues
right and they're also dialectical that
means that they're able to carry on
reasoned discussions but they're also
some protocols that means they're a good
dinner guest right or a good drinking
partner and they're also a royalty costs
which means that they are in some way a
good lover now
what's what's going on there in those
passages there's you know there are some
you could say stoic ascetic distrust of
sexuality and sexual desire and and in
the present it would it extend to all
the sort of stuff that we've you know
surrounded that with you know the whole
notion of dating and stuff like that I
think there would be Stoics if they were
brought to the the present who'd be
looking at things like tinder and saying
maybe not such a great idea right but if
you if you look at what they're saying
about how people ought to try
each other then I think that the Stoics
who don't say a lot directly about
marriage for example or about you know
romantic relationships in general or
about sexual desire or sexual activity
have a lot to contribute to us in the
present so you know you can think about
the the notion of hooking up right in
the past that was although it was
frowned upon in in you know most
cultures and sometimes could get you in
a lot of trouble you know for
fornication or something like that it
was going on all the time right I mean
we have lots of literature about this
thinking about Boccaccio's Decameron
which you know or you know ovens art of
love or you know Catullus making fun of
other people in ancient Rome for being
terrible lovers or things like that well
that's been going on for a long time and
now in our society with the risk with
you know exceptions in certain
subcultures I'd say it's been pretty
normalized right the idea that you're
not just going to wait until you get
married before engaging in sexual
activity and that maybe you'll you'll
have you know like a serial monogamy
sort of thing or people dating different
people well that can be done in ways
that are prudent or imprudent right I
mean you could apply the virtues to that
I mean and that's going to preclude a
lot of screwing around with many people
because you can you know just look at
some people's profiles and be like man
that person's a mess better not get
involved with them and we can think
about justice you know what do people
actually OE each other we can think
about courage ghosting people is
generally not a courageous move it's the
move of a coward right and we could talk
about temperance temperance has to do
with the regulation of our appetites and
and you know if you're constantly on the
make well you're probably going to be
unhappy we can think about Valentine's
Day that just came around right a time
of great anxiety for for people in and
out of relationships am I going to do
things right what do I need to do to
make my my partner happy what if I'm
alone on Valentine's Days at the end of
the world am I a failure
the Stoics I think offer us a lot of
useful
ideas for you know thinking about those
those fears or anxieties or sorrows and
seeing whether those those emotional
reactions are actually in line so you
know like I'm saying here there's
there's a lot of food for thought let me
see what's going on in the stream here
so a lot of chitchat at the beginning
about what we're doing okay so here's a
question from Caitlin if you identify as
bisexual or asexual doesn't that just
mean that you just like people or does
it indicate something more okay good
question I mean and these things are
getting more and more not so much
bisexual or asexual but there's like all
these different sexual things that
people are putting out there and I mean
- sexual right where you're like yeah
I'm not quite sure what that means and
so you asked five people and you get
five different answers I think there's a
lot of flux going on at the moment so
you know if somebody is identifying as
bisexual that has to do with attraction
that means that they're attracted to
both both sexes right and in a certain
respect since you know people now like
it this entire spectrum being bisexuals
kind of old hat isn't it right asexual
means that you're started removing
yourself or not so much deliberately but
in terms of affection you're not really
attracted to anybody it in a sexual way
right now that doesn't preclude the
possibility of deep abiding friendships
or anything like that
I always feel very sorry for these
people who think that they they can't
really be friends with say people of the
opposite sex or people who don't have
their orientation you know like like
straight people who can't be can't be
friends with people who are gay or
lesbian or bisexual or vice versa you
know because you're you're removing
yourself from the pool of you know
possible friendship relationships which
may have nothing to do with romance you
know but a lot of people get quite mixed
up about these things again I think sort
of applying
ideas and modes of analysis too that
could be quite useful thinking about
Epictetus and talking about what he
calls appearances you know you you have
an idea in your mind I can't be friends
with this person because I'm attracted
to them you could actually be both right
or I can't be friends with this person
because I don't share the mode of
Attraction with them they're they're
attracted to different kinds of people
than I am well that's a that's an
impression or an appearance that is not
necessarily a reality an epic epic
tedious like the other stoic says we
should question those sorts of things so
now the doesn't doesn't don't these
designations just mean that you just
like people know every designation is a
way somebody generally self identifies
or somebody identifies them along either
you know what they view as sex or gender
and people you know there's a lot of
discussion about well what is what with
that or along axes of Attraction so
that's it's a good question
let's see what else we got here Oh looks
like we've got quite a few petros what
is a good academic introduction to
stoicism book or article I mean there's
no substitute for actually reading the
texts read Marcus Aurelius you know if
you I mean you could go out and get you
know John salaries or you know Chris
Gill or some of the other people that
I'm involved with the modern stoicism
project and I'm you know they're books
are great as a matter of fact getting to
meet Chris Gill is like you know an
amateur musician or intermediate level
musician getting to meet a rock star
right for me but III don't see why you
would want to not go right into reading
Epictetus or Seneca or Marcus Aurelius
and then go get some academic books and
then you know and it also depends to on
what you're interested in like if you're
really interested in stoicism out of
motion then you want to read Margaret
ravers stoicism out of motion right
if you're really interested in stoicism
and virtue ethics Chris Gill has a new
book coming out pretty soon on that so
yeah a lot of questions here about
introductions or at best introduction of
stoic metaphysics again reading the
Stoics but you know I don't know I know
I don't really do a lot of introductory
literature most of the stuff that I
actually do look at that gets sent to me
for review tends to be more popular
stuff if you want it there is a there is
a book about the stoic physics I don't
remember who it's by but it's it's
decent
let me just google stoic physics book
and it'll come up and you know there
isn't any such thing as stoic
metaphysics as a separate discipline
right the Stoics divided philosophy into
logic physics and and ethics
so metaphysics would kind of fit in with
with the physics there Maria I'm
wondering why did the concept of stoic
development such a different meaning
nowadays rather than the original
philosophical term well that's a good
question I think part of that is because
people would take what they wanted very
selectively from the Stoics
epictetus was somebody who became very
commonly read in the you know after the
Renaissance in the early modern period
and a lot of people would read his stuff
and then they would only pay attention
to like you know a third of what they
read very common right many people are
not particularly good readers so they
would they would take from it especially
guys would take you know the sort of
being tough not allowing fate - you know
grind you down don't let your emotions
Drive you sort of sort of things from it
and they did this with Marcus Aurelius
as well and then that was stoicism for
them and then that became part of the
common vocabulary in the 19th century
and you know the use of the lowercase s
quite often and you know over time as as
you know the population became
more and more literate it doesn't mean
they actually became better read and
many people would you know buy these
sort of popular philosophy things and
learn about the the Stoics as being
these people who counselled not having
any emotions they don't often fit into
the sort of history of philosophy as
kind of a side note as well and then we
it became part of the the common
parlance where we would talk about say
soldiers or sport's figures as being
stoic not allowing the pain that they
feel to get to them and you know driving
on with their duty and I think that a
lot of people whine wind up only
learning that I'll mention that the
American Philosophical adji Association
you know recently they got themselves
into some controversy by saying that
that some aspects of traditional
masculinity not all that some were
actually psychologically detrimental and
they used the word stoicism in their
lowercase s they didn't target the
philosophy as such and I had all these
people right way what do you think about
the APA and I was like I don't know I
mean I don't pay that much attention to
them anyway what they do now and and I
looked at it and I read the guidelines
and I was like you know unless you're
kind of primed to overreact this is
pretty mainstream stuff you know that
they're saying it isn't good to like
stuff all your emotions down that's
that's not what the ancient Stoics were
suggesting that's not what my aren't
psychologists suggest that but that is a
sort of prevalent view of what it means
to be stoic alright let's see medics I
guess what do I think about Kabbalah and
science concepts Big Bang evolution I
don't pay any attention in the Kabbalah
in part cuz that's not something I have
time you know many times my answer is I
don't have time to do this I don't have
time to look at that I get the same 24
hours as everybody else
aesthetics is also asking what about
paranormality demonology no I don't have
time to dig around and things like that
I was interested in some of those things
when I was a
kid and a teenager and you know not
anymore the Big Bang I you know so
there's a big bang we don't actually
know much about it it was an idea by the
way that came it was proposed by a
Jesuit priest who was a scientist and
most of the scientists at the time were
like nobody is ever gonna believe that
nonsense evolution which which theory of
evolution there's many of them out there
I think you know we just sort of take
these these things into account but you
know I I don't have time to focus on the
things that I actually do focus on which
are largely in classical philosophy and
some things in religious studies but
pretty mainstream stuff you know let's
see what do I think of ants combs modern
moral philosophy so you're referencing
the article that she has talking about
modern moral philosophy I think that on
the whole she's right if you confine
yourself to thinking about the
english-speaking world and you confine
yourself to ignoring much of the
American classical you know
philosophical tradition which includes
the pragmatist but also Jonathan Edwards
and also arrestees Bronson and you know
people like that or the st. Louis or
galleons I think that she's right that
it tends to be rather artificially
focused on rules and laws and you know
reduces things to basically
utilitarianism or deontology and ignored
virtue ethics I think it's incredibly
provincial in that even in Britain you
had many figures who were you know doing
work in virtue ethics long before ants
comb and her lot like you know brought
about its Renaissance many of them were
in religious schools you know so I think
that she's an important part of the
picture but I don't you know by for an
instant that like you know virtue ethics
was was totally in decline and then had
this revival know it wasn't I mean you
just have to read around in order to see
that that's false and read some some
French and German
philosophy of the 20th century or some
it's an Italian stuff or Spanish stuff
you know a lot of its available in
translation
we often get like the in the field of
philosophy there's a larger picture
we often get this like you know very
myopic view from people only talking to
their their limited colleagues in their
university and then they think well
that's the entirety of philosophy I mean
the idea that like Vidkun Stein
rediscovered language another great
example no he didn't
I mean the entire like semiotic
semiology thing was going on throughout
Europe all over the place Vic and I
didn't actually know anything about it
muted these other Oxford types so
alright have you ever studied any Adorno
given his proximity and development on
Hegel yeah as a matter of fact one of my
earliest publications is on Adorno you
can find it in Minerva it's called the
three something three three varieties of
critique or something I haven't looked
at it for a very long time but it's been
anthologized from time to time and
literature and and cited quite a bit so
yeah I studying some Adorno Adorno is an
interesting guy you know and he's fun to
read very challenging to read not
somebody who I've spent any time on
lately but I almost wrote my my master's
thesis on Adorno instead I wrote it on
who Cyril and dis so sir and and
language all right um let's see what
else we've got here Lana here we go
bibliography readings is from Maria what
texture authors would you recommend
about this topic I mean your are you
asking about how to do a bibliography
there's lots of resources online you can
take a look at I don't know what
bibliography readings would mean so
alright retro gamer are not appearances
the resistance needed from Cod elapses
you could never get away from
appearances
as a matter of fact there are kind of
left DK fantasy i right
which means ones that we're not going to
be wrong about where we have an adequate
grasp on them this is a stoic going back
to stoic stuff I'm not sure what you
mean by the resistance needed in this
case but you can say that you know
appearances are something that that the
Stoics devoted a lot of a lot of thought
to sort of distinguishing and figuring
out how we ought to approach them and
not not immediately give a scent to them
and you know to go back to this issue of
romantic relationships there's so much
where we make wide sweeping assumptions
based on so little information and then
we don't check in with the person
because of you know fear or anger or or
some other thing or you know some some
cultural baggage that we're carrying
into the relationship and the Stoics
would say we'd be a lot better off
actually like sitting down and talking
with the person and figuring out what's
going on and you know the other thing
too I've been thinking about this
recently so let me let me bounce this
off of all of you I was gonna write a
piece of about this thinking about the
the conception of the friendzone right
you get all these guys and there are
some women too granted right and and
this goes across the entire like gender
sexuality attraction spectrum it's a
perennial problem you get all these
people who are like I'm stuck in the
friend zone what can I do and I'm gonna
use this sort of heteronormative you
know guy girl thing because it's it's so
well talked about what can I do to get
her to notice me and you know my answer
to that is Jesus you're lucky you got a
good friend hold on to that don't screw
that up right just find somebody else
who but I'm not attracted to somebody
else well you know give it a couple
weeks and you probably will be that's
the way sexual attraction works you know
an infatuation it's not like you're
gonna meet somebody most likely when
you're 18 years old they're 25 and they
are the only person that could ever make
you happy in the world I mean maybe that
does happen occasionally I you know I
think that I've got my my soul mate
that by itself doesn't like solve
everything that just that gives you a
new perspective with its own new set of
challenges and issues that you got to
work through but any given one single
person you meet is probably not that
right and so how fortunate you are
here's what a stoic and say how
fortunate you are that you actually have
a good friend because a friend is a
valuable thing to begin with and now
somebody who could actually give you
insight about the very kinds of people
that you're attracted to isn't that
actually lucky for you why would you
screw that up right and you know you can
so you go out and find somebody else and
don't do it to try to make them jealous
or something like that because that's
still being attracted to that person
think about it as having this wonderful
opportunity for a sounding board and you
get to be friends and if you break up
with that that other person then you've
got somebody to actually go and vent to
and you know hear how things aren't so
bad or how they were never the right
person or stuff like that and if there's
gonna be like some big movie finale you
know oh we were always the ones for each
other at the end well that'll happen
then doesn't have to happen upfront
right so I've been thinking about doing
some some writing about about that sort
of thing and that would going back to
the retro game or question I mean a lot
of that it would have to do with
appearances and how how we react to them
alright Tomica is there the Stoics have
an account of time yeah they considered
it to be one of the one of the sort of
fundamental things as a matter of fact
Seneca mentions this in latter 65 where
he's talking about the Aristotelian and
platonic causes he says they left things
out and one of them is time so the
Stoics yeah I did have a conception we
don't have any like treatise on time but
they certainly thought it was it was
something all right
aesthetics more questions what about the
occult Saren occult and worship Shiva
there's a virtual video of ritual I I
don't care I mean what is it what does
any of that have to do with stoicism to
begin with and what does any of that
have to do
me so alright let's see what else we got
here
Oh Robert what is love okay so that's a
good question right there we're getting
to something fundamental and maybe it's
something we're where we probably should
distinguish different modalities of love
and this is what you know a good
philosophy of love and sex and desire
would do it wouldn't say all love is
exactly the same thing it would
distinguish different types you know and
and you can see people doing this in the
history of philosophy the Stoics did do
that too
so I mentioned areas didymus and areas
didymus talks about two different kinds
of love in the epitome of stoic ethics
one of which we might if we want to call
o Conte and that's called pathological
right in the sense that it's it's uh
it's appealing to pathos it's not really
rational it's going to get us in trouble
and we you know we get inflamed with
desire and then we make a lot of dumb
decisions and try to impress people and
say stupid things that we want to take
back later and you know make silly
financial decisions and and and you know
all sorts of things like that and then
and then we have love which is an actual
affection as well as the first one but
it's it's it's rational a lot of people
think that reason somehow means like
turning off your emotions not the case
at all in ancient philosophy it just
means like channeling them properly you
want to have your emotions properly
integrated with your rationality it's
not like this you know sort of dr. Spock
or not dr. Spock mr. Spock all right dr.
Spock was the baby guy mr. Spock is the
Star Trek guy it's not like that a
person who who is fully rational would
be emotional they would be emotional in
such a way as their emotions in and
rationality integrate and harmonize with
each other and help to add to each other
so to people who actually are in love
with each other and have you know
developed a
would in fact people have something
really great right alright Michael
Pullman can you provide names links I'm
not gonna provide links to anything here
because that means like typing on the
keyboard to lesser-known ancients Stoics
Heracles not Heracles hero please
the stoic yeah he's a guy who we we have
a few writings from we don't have
everything that the guy wrote apparently
we don't a most stoic literature so
lesser known ancient Stoics I mean
that's something you could actually like
Google just look at the Wikipedia entry
on stoic philosophers and see which ones
you know about we don't have text from
most of them so it doesn't do you much
good to know their names the ones that
we do have texts from you know or or we
know about are largely through other
intermediaries so for example if you
want to know about the ancient Stoics
you need to read Cicero Cicero was not a
stoic he was an eclectic who identified
with the academic school but identified
in such a way as to be an eclectic he
draws heavily on stoic thought and he
also tells us what the Stoics thought
about things this is before we get to
the the later
you know Roman Stoics Cicero is
recording what the earlier early and
middle stoas had to say about things so
you want to read stoic paradoxes and on
the ends and on Duty's and on the nature
of the gods and academics and on
divination and on fate and things like
that right or you want to look at if you
want to know about Stoics on the
emotions you probably want to read some
gala
again not a stoic as a matter of fact an
opponent of the Stoics in certain
respects but some of the stoic doctrines
are preserved it in same thing about
Plutarch Plutarch ism is a middle plate
inist but he tells us about the stoic so
you've got those guys then you've got
you know the big three
Epictetus seneca
marcus aurelius you should read them if
you if you're interested in stoicism
they should be your go-to guys over and
over again loose audience Rufus we do
have some of his stuff and then there's
here achlys and arias didymus and that's
I mean there's there's fragments here
and there but that's that's more or less
what we've what we've got to work with
all right Danielle how does stoic deal
with a childhood friend who constantly
steers conversation into homophobic
Islamophobic or racist directions
abandon the friendship or continue to
try to mend it I think a you know a
classic stoic would say try to mend it
but that doesn't mean that you like put
up with everything you'd want to make
clear to them listen we're not in
agreement on this I like you as a person
but there's some things where I'm you
know you should you should decide for
yourself what's more important our
relationship or getting to be say a
homophobe right if you're gonna
continually be making gay jokes and
expect me to laugh at them that's not
going to be something I'm cool with you
know and eventually the other thing to
realize too is well you can make it
clear to them how you view things and
what you know the consequences of things
are they're not in your control it's not
it's up to them what they're what they
want to do if they want to you know take
offense and get all worked up and you
know say slander you you know someone
throws a terrible friend they broke
those things up they put it on Facebook
or Twitter or not there's nothing you
can can do to prevent them from doing
that but that's their business right
that's not you being a bad person that's
them being a bad person I think and this
is something else to point out very
often we we need other people to be our
sort of moral regulators in the sense
that they say to us hey you're screwing
up this this isn't this isn't cool I
like you but you're really being a jerk
or a jackass right now and and you got
to stop doing this not stop doing this
where I'm at ik oligo break break things
off with you but I don't want to be with
you when you're doing this you're making
it really hard for me to hang out with
you you know you're making it more
difficult for me to attend to your good
good features those are the sorts of
things that we often need to hear right
and very often other people need to hear
them we probably when we're doing it if
we are doing it as Stoics we'd want to
think about okay how am I gonna rehearse
it ahead of time this is where you know
some stoic techniques like negative
visualization could be quite helpful
before you go into the difficult
conversation play it out in your head
think about where the person might you
know take it off the rails so to speak
and then what you might do what
resources you would have how do you
respond to that right and then you know
keep your expectations low exercise the
so called reserve Clause right fate
willing I will get through to this
person but I don't control that but I
think that's an important thing to do
that is a part of justice I would say
for the Stoics you know we there's
old-fashioned language about this in the
older texts like admonishing right but
admonishing means going to your friend
and saying man you're screwing up look
at this crap that you've been doing you
can't go on like this buddy that's
that's the sort of thing that just
people do in relation to each other and
again to go back to romantic
relationships
that's that sometimes an important part
of that this is a theme that's not only
recognized by like the Stoics or by
Aristotle but was a big thing in
medieval times too you know spouses and
that's how they thought about it in
terms of spouses right those who are
connected through conjugal love should
you know point out not in a nun
charitable way but point out that the
other person is screwing up when they're
screwing up and then hopefully they can
they can you know respond appropriately
to that so that's a great question
all right Maura's guy you know one of my
thoughts on Jill Toulouse talked about
this many times to lose as an
interesting guy when you read to lose
another philosophers you get more to
lose than you get the philosopher I like
to lose not big on delusions canal levee
the the cynics differ from the Stoics in
anyway on love that's a great question
so you think about what differentiates
the cynics from the Stoics one part is
the cynics made a huge show not only did
they do this but they've made a huge
show of flouting social convention right
the Stoics much more willing to say you
know we need to to actually follow what
our roles are our duties those are often
given to us socially so cynics for
example would have no problem you know
like like the Beatles song says doing it
in the road right Stoics no they
wouldn't be doing that oh I think that
that's that's part of it
there weren't many cynics as far as we
know who were actually married cratis
and hip Archaea would be an exception
rather than the rule and they were both
unusual people I mean hip Archaea was
not an ordinary woman and she cracked a
section you shouldn't be with me this is
a tough life and she's like I'm going
for it I think that that's a wonderful
way to live and they seem to have been
quite happy stoic should be more more
conventional about that that sort of
thing I think you know and the Stoics
provide us from what we've got again
we've lost a lot of ancient literature
the Stoics provide us with a lot more
useful advice and techniques and modes
of analysis that we could use I think
all right Elwood
can the ethical really be set in line
with what Vidkun Stein said well which
fit Kim Stein earlier late right if
we're talking about early vic and stein
saying the the ethical is some
you know in the realm of the unsayable
it's about value I mean he repudiated
that the track goddess later so I you
know MIT consign I've pointed this out
before I think he would have been
somebody who would have really benefited
by a much wider reading in the history
of philosophy brilliant guy really
interesting insights a lot of
reinventing of the wheel and I'd love to
have seen what if he'd actually engaged
seriously with the tradition what he
might have done in ethics but I don't I
don't see much there to go on all right
in the study of philosophy is from
Christian should I begin with the Greeks
and move chronologically or could I read
some 20th century philosophy can read
some supplementary books or articles you
can do whatever you like I mean that's a
cool thing it's not like you're gonna
hurt your brain by reading it the wrong
way you know like you you have to read
the fundamental stuff first and get the
code down no you really read what you
want if you want to start
chronologically I say start with Plato
don't even bother with the pre-socratics
you could always go back and look at
them right you're gonna get some of them
through Plato and Aristotle anyway and
it's not like once you've read it once
you know what what if I get Heraclitus
run by reading Plato well then you're
reading it way too rigidly right you you
should always be ready to revise by
going back to to better sources what
what you what you have to to say right
or what you think about something but
you know I didn't read chronologically I
mean I jumped all around all over the
place but then again I've been reading
philosophy since I was a teenager not
always well not always systematically
but you know it's something that's an
accumulative process and and it gets it
you you get a bigger better conception
of how things fit in with each other
provided you've got you know some some
some mental flexibility you don't get a
map where like everybody's got their
little you know container that you put
them in you get a better conception over
time of how all these these pea
will fit in with each other McCoy even
Seneca I was amazing a thinker and
writer as he was was a terrible person
you know I like to avoid that kind of
hyperbole you know amazing terrible no
he was he was a great thinker I mean we
not to say he's an amazing thinker he's
he's good you know but he wasn't a
terrible person I mean he was also a
pretty good person he wasn't great in
every single respect but you know yeah
all right Danielle can you speak to any
stoic contributions to the Christian
theological tradition um yeah I mean a
lot of Christian thinkers used you know
stoic analyses of the emotions and the
soul and incorporated them into their
own Christian anthropology a lot of them
were where you know you usually hear
this line the early church fathers were
all neoplatonist yeah okay
but the neoplatonist thought that Plato
when it came to the metaphysics he had
that stuff right and then when it came
to the actual world that we live in then
either the Aristotelian or the Stoics or
a combination of them got it right so
the the neoplatonist quite often had a
lot of stoic stuff mixed in there you
know of Agrius Ponte kisses eight evil
thoughts that become the eight capital
vices in John Cassian that later on
through a set of transformations turn
into the seven deadly sins well a lot of
that is pretty similar to stomach
conceptions of you know wrong ways of
thinking that lead is done down the
wrong paths that we can identify with
particular emotional complexes so
there's all sorts of things you know the
there's conflux is between Christian
morality and stoic morality and a lot of
points quite a few you know Christians
were willing to recognize that that
early Greek philosophy while even the
philosophy of the Greek philosophy of
their own time was not something simply
to reject but something to take the best
parts of it incorporate clement of
alexandria is a great example of that
rights have I read a new history of
Western philosophy written by Anthony
Kenny what's your thoughts on the author
of the book Kennedy is an interesting
guy I've never taken him like super
seriously McIntyre likes him and
recommends him but that's because they
were actually friends i I think that
Kenny I haven't read the the new history
of Western philosophy I don't spend a
lot of time reading histories of
philosophy frankly and I'm spending a
lot of time reading primary texts
I don't even spend a lot of time reading
secondary texts that are like a history
of something but focused on one thing
but I mean Kennedy Kenny is is uh he's
an interesting sort he really does you
know where he stands on things he's
often I think quite wrong and how he
interprets things you know he's got an
entire book Aristotle's theory of the
will Aristotle doesn't have a theory if
the will yeah he has a conception of
prior ASUS you know and and Kenny took
part in the Blackfyre Blackfriars
translation of Thomas Aquinas some of
the stuff that Kenny translated is where
you're like wow this stuff is really
gonna be misleading to a reader who
can't read the Latin because Kenny made
all these interpretive choices so I mean
when I hear that something's coming out
from Kenny I imagine it's gonna be well
written
I don't always imagine that it's gonna
be exactly on point
so yeah but again I haven't read it so
he could be an exception to the rule all
right
Tomica is can you have an account of
ethics without a metaphysical or
epistemic one sure yeah I mean people do
all the time it doesn't mean you don't
have metaphysics and epistemology
lurking in the background just like you
can't actually do metaphysics and
epistemology without making some moral
assumptions about value and things like
that but you don't have to have an
explicit you know set of studies or
foundation in place before you can do
ethics so yeah some are asked
did did I teach the core objection of
Gunilla as well as an Psalms response
can I fight a bit about that in my
channel best way to do that as always
search right everything's there that's
there no I haven't done Gunilla
objections he doesn't have a objection
he has objections and Ansem has a long
response to him that's not something
that you would probably just do one core
concept video on if I ever do get around
to it that'll probably be quite a bit
more all right Alexander if I thought
about doing a video about Taoism or loud
so it drums ax or late sue again when I
you know these days when I when I want
to treat a topic I don't do a video I do
like a series of videos but I'm I'm you
know more leery about doing stuff in in
philosophical traditions where I can't
actually read the original and I have to
be very reliant upon other people's
translations so you know and I'm not an
expert in Taoism right so I am an expert
say in Descartes or Aristotle or Thomas
Hobbes so I don't know if I if I'll ever
do that and the other factor is time
right if I had more time on my hands I
can I can produce more video content but
right now I spend a lot of my time
earning a living so either teaching for
academic institutions or doing a
tutorial work or consulting or all of
that sort of stuff that's why I started
the patreon thing right to to slowly
provide a income that lets me do more
more creative work all right
ah let's see it just skipped here again
let me scroll up a little bit a lot of
questions here I'm not gonna be able to
get to to everything okay
so retro gamer okay that's Nick and
McCain ethics yeah I've got a course on
that that he's mentioning and the reason
I like
to me Arvid is it true that Christian
tradition of communal living in
monasteries is taken directly from
epicurean communes no there there are a
lot of different experiments with
communal living the Epicureans were only
one of many but the Christian tradition
of monasteries you know that that's it's
got its own history
stellate you know when it comes to
things it's really rare that you can
like point say well they got this
directly from these people over over
here
Petros would be a good way of preparing
for a philosophy bachelor program
reading philosophy I'd say you know
speaking with people about philosophy
there is no like consistency I actually
had an interesting exchange with
somebody in my Facebook page where he
was really under the impression that
there's like a standard curriculum for
philosophy and you know this school had
failed and teaching this and this you
know and I was like man you don't know
how how fragmented things are you know I
mean even even like teaching at
Marquette where I'm teaching this
foundations a philosophy class we had a
meeting so this is just one school right
we have this core class foundations in
philosophy the chair with all the
instructors there propose that maybe we
have one common reading that would be
one text that all of us have the
students read so that there's some
consistency and they were like they were
mad they did not want to hear that
they're you know so there's there's no
like standard thing for for what a
philosophy ba program is gonna look like
the best thing to do I would say is
start getting some philosophical texts
under your belt and you know read them
as a beginner read them realizing you're
gonna reread them the next time around
all right
Maria is philosophy something that must
be studied as a formal student at
college or university or everyone can't
reach the same by studying important
thinkers yes both right it can be done
some people need to study it as a formal
student because they need that structure
and sometimes depending on you know
how motivated you are it might be good
to actually have a teacher sometimes you
have professors who open your your eyes
to things that you wouldn't have come
across right
not everybody can reach the same by
studying important thinkers but not
everybody even like becomes a good
student of philosophy by being in a
program then how to self teach us in the
right way well that's that's a more
individual thing there's different ways
people go about that that's that's one
of the things I do in my business is
help people set up programs for
self-study so I don't have any any you
know one-size-fit-all kind of guidelines
to to give you on that fruiting body
reviews do you think there could be an
ethical world one day sure I mean we
have a halfway ethical world right now
right
it's just shot through with all sorts of
stuff that are unethical you know so why
not increase it speaking of monasteries
is from arvid since you're Catholic and
a fan of sci-fi what do you think in the
canticle for Leibowitz canticle for
Leibowitz is great the follow up
terrible I was so disappointed when I
read the the sequel to it and I may I
may in fact put that into the worlds of
sci-fi ori worlds of speculative fiction
sometime but the reason I didn't was
because there's only really these two
books in the series and the second one
is just such drivel and garbage but the
first one was really great
I like that okay let's see I'm scroll
down a little bit
mark Martine why is Nietzsche often
characterized as an anti stoic because
nature was because Nietzsche declared
himself as such right in those those
rather tendentious lines where he
accuses the Stoics of not understanding
nature then trying to impose their own
idea of nature I think that that's
arguably anti stoic right
max Kauai why are they relatively few
works unloved by moderns relative to
ancients I don't think that's actually
the case I think there's lots of works
on love by moderns you just got a dig a
bit to find them I mean for example did
the card have anything to say about love
yes there's an entire thing called on
the passions of the soul and that talks
about love in there so that's probably a
good place to go to you know you've got
a you got a survey the thing to really
make that sort of declaration let's see
I'll scroll down
[Music]
Oh Maria if we place stomachs today what
would they say about globalization do
you think he could agree with taking out
our individual cultures dropping them
into a general moist Western
idiosyncrasy I guess if that's what you
mean about globalization they might be
against it but globalization is one of
those slippery ambiguous terms it
doesn't just mean one thing right so I
think Stoics would be very concerned
about how the process of what we call
globalization in an economic sense is
really taking things out of the control
of any sort of local decision-making and
essentially a strip mining the planet in
ways that are probably going to screw it
up for the rest of us and they would
call that imprudent and unjust and there
are modern-day Stoics out there making
that case right now so Plymouth roll
over rock over rock rock roll over there
we go with the exception of Augustine it
seems fear the Church Fathers are
discussed in philosophy courses are
their works that should be of interest
to non-christian readers is Paul a
philosopher no Paul's not a philosopher
the Paul is not a church father either
Paul is is you know from time of
Scripture yeah I mean who would be other
good church fathers to read John Cassian
I'm a big fan of clement of alexandria
locked on seus
you know Justin Martyr John Chrysostom
is definitely worth reading John to
masking there's a lot of there's a lot
of people that are good to read I
include some of them sometimes in my
classes when I can but it's tough to get
you know with a philosophy class the
challenges we usually get a pack so much
stuff in there and and we don't get to
go into great depth and detail on it so
it's it's a matter of triage we're like
well I got 15 weeks on damn their spring
break in there too and like this days
off now I got thirteen and a half weeks
Who am I going to cover sometimes it's
actually mandated like which people we
have to cover as well depending on the
school so all right Adam Teeter what are
your thoughts on the so-called hoax why
is Lacan still important considering is
wrong use of mathematical terminology so
let me just put that into to why is
Lacan still important because he has way
greater insights than anything about
mathematical terminology you just ignore
that [ __ ] right if who cares about
the graphs and all that sort of crap I
mean I was a math major so when I when I
come to Lacan I look at that I'm like
what the hell is this crap
so there's a lot of other great insights
you know the unconscious is struck is
structured like a language totally
independent of anything having to do
with mathematics and you know with you
know I'm pointed this out many many
times if you want to understand Lacan
don't get the acree get the seminars
read your way through those first you
know why deliberately choose the things
where he likes to be an obscurantist
you know the so-called hoax yeah I mean
there's plenty of I mean I was in
continental philosophy I knew who the
[ __ ] artists were because you can
tell them a mile away because when you
start unraveling what they're saying
there's nothing actually there the
so-called hoax was taken way too far by
a lot of people who are like well see
the fields themselves are you know just
just garbage that's stupid that's that's
a stupid conclusion to draw you know you
know you want to know if there
anything to dairy down you read dairy
that you don't just give it like a
surface read you actually do the work to
read say on grandma Tala G and if you do
you'll find out it's an actually
rigorous work that's making a lot of the
same points that are made by other
philosophers and other fields and in
other times it'll be a big surprise to
you of course if you're going by dairy
does reputation and then you read
something else you know like I know the
ear of the other and you're like well
this is [ __ ] but you actually have
to dig into it to find anything out and
I think the problem with Sokol hoaxes is
they're so superficial that they run
themselves to a certain kind of making
oneself stupid or maintaining oneself in
stupidity and ignorance on the part of
the people who want to think that
they've now like proven that something
is is is uh you know valueless write
literature corner is there any point in
living if one is ugly I lost my look
some time ago and being stoic about it
isn't helping
well they being stoic about it doesn't
mean just like saying oh I'm not gonna
let it bother me being stoic about it
means thinking about well why does this
bother me that's doing analysis right so
this goes back to the lowercase s
uppercase s thing I was talking about at
the beginning real stoicism means
studying the Stoics applying their
thoughts you know if physical
attractiveness is what's really
important to you and you want to change
that first you have to figure out why
that's so important to you the Stoics
for doing something kind of like
psychological counseling worth a and
then you start read once you actually
have an understanding of how your psyche
works then you start fixing things with
it and you do so by deliberate choice
alright Adam said I forgot everything I
wanted to ask well that's that you know
that happens stone crow it's nice to see
a live chat that isn't full of dummies
for once well you got to go to the right
places I guess right let's see what we
one o'clock so I'm gonna have to get off
very soon let's see it we've got
I can jump into very quickly retro game
here's a good question this applies to
stoic stuff - would it be cool to output
excerpts and ideas or Maxim's from
Aquinas system Metallica I am NOT a fan
of you know excerpting little bits and
pieces of things I think Senecas totally
right when he's talking to Luke Ilyas
and Luke Ilyas wants him to give him
stoic Maxim's and Senecas like that's a
terrible idea buddy you know unless
you're they're actually grounded within
the larger system they don't actually do
you any good they wind up you know
leading you astray and the whole like
we're gonna put you know inspirational
quotes with oftentimes the wrong head of
somebody like they get Marcus Aurelius
wrong or they put Epicurus in Epictetus
is placed right for his face and then
they have like one line which may or may
not actually be from that philosopher
because oftentimes false quotes are
attributed to them that's a terrible way
to do philosophy it's not actually going
to help you you have to like you got to
dig into it and and find out what the
matrix of the philosophy is so that you
can you can do something with it all
right so we've covered a lot of ground
here there's there's quite a few
questions that I haven't gotten to but
we're not going to have the time to do
them
I'll do another one of these on Facebook
a little bit later this month patreon
supporters already know when it's
happening because I give them the the
dates for these in advance everybody
else will find out the day of as I
posted in social media so hope you had a
decent Valentine's Day whether you're
single or in a relationship and you know
read the Stoics spend some time reading
reading through them and seeing what you
can actually do with them doesn't mean
you have to buy into the totality of
what they're teaching but there's a lot
of really valuable stuff there so
alright I'll see you all of you